>> Greg:
AND SO DO YOU.
I HOPE YOU ARE WELL.
THIS WEEK THE MEDIA FINALLY
DISCOVERED CRIME BECAUSE FINALL
THEY FOUND A CRIMINAL WHO FITS
THE BILL AS THEY IGNORE OTHERS
WHO DON'T.
TO MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS IS A
FELON AND I CREDIT THE OUTRAGE
EVEN IF MOST OF BET ONLY TO US
EXPLOIT A TRAGEDY.
THE POLITICAL REPORTER CONCLUDE
THAT WHITE AMERICANS AREN'T
DOING ENOUGH TO FIGHT RACISM
PERSPEX IT IS REALLY A WHITE
CULTURE BOWL PROBLEM THAT WHY
YES THAT THAT AFRICAN-AMERICANS
ARE MORE GENERALLY SEEN AS THE
OTHER OR SO EASILY --
WE TALK ABOUT WHITE SUPREMACY
BUT IT'S ALSO THE WAY IN WHICH
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT FOLKS COMING
ACROSS THE BORE.
IT GOES ROUND WITH THOSE FOLKS
AND ALSO ARE A THREAT.
>> SO RACISM IS A WHITE
BICULTURAL PROBLEM AND WHITES
SHOULD COME TO TERMS WITH IT.
HOW DOES SHE KNOW THAT THEY
HAVEN'T WHAT PLANET IS SHE ON
WHY THEY ONLY GET CNN AND MSNBC
THERE APPEARED SHE ECHOES WHAT
HER.
SAY, THAT WHITES SHARE THE GUIL
FOR THEIR RACIST ACTIONS AS IF
INDIVIDUAL CHOICE,
RESPONSIBILITY, OR MENTAL
ILLNESS DON'T EXIST ONLY BY
UNITING PIGMENT THAT UNITES US.
MEANWHILE THIS DOPE THINGS THOS
THAT EMBRACE FREE SPEECH DO SO
AND OUR RACES.
>> LOOK AT THE WAY THE RIGHT TR
TO BAPTIZE THE DEPTH THAT DHS
WAS GOING TO ESSENTIALLY TRY TO
ATTEMPT TO MONITOR HATEFUL
RHETORIC.
THEY WANT TO MAKE IT SEEM AS IF
IT IS SOME SORT OF A BROTHER.
IT'S LIKE THIS IS ALWAYS WHAT
THE RIGHT DOES TO APPEASE THE
WHITE SUPREMACIST MOVEMENT BY
SAYING, HEY, FREE SPEECH.
>> SO IF YOU ARE FOR FREE SPEECH
, YOU'RE HELPING OUT THE
KKK.
THAT IS A LEAP THAT EVIL KNIEVE
COULDN'T MAKE MSNBC, MAYBE IT I
TIME TO CHUCK TODD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THANK YOU.
TERRIBLE POND.
I'VE DISCUSSED MYSELF HE IS THE
TURNED, TOURED WITH A HEAD
INJURY UNDER A HAIRPIECE.
I COULD GO ON FOREVER AND THEN
THERE'S THIS GUY SAY WE NEED A
NEW WAR ON TERROR, THE
TERRORISTS BEING REPUBLICANS.
>> MIKE GUIDANCES THAT WE HAVE
TO TREAT AS A TERRORIST THREAT
THAT IT IS.
WE RALLY ON 911.
THERE WAS NO QUESTION ABOUT WHA
THE COUNTRY WAS GOING TO DO.
WE ARE FACING THE SAME THREAT W
SHOULD LABEL THEM AT THAT
DOMESTIC TERRORIST PARTY.
>> AND THEY SAY REPUBLICANS ARE
DIVISIVE PITS OF THIS IS RAISES
THE QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S RAISE
BY IDIOTS.
ARE YOU RESPONSIBLE FOR A PERSON
'S CRIME BECAUSE YOU SHARE
A PIGMENT.
AND HAS A NET FEDERAL INTO EVER
WHITE PERSON'S HEAD THAT SINCE
THEY WERE KIDS NOT TO DO THIS
KIND OF GENERALIZING, ESPECIALL
WHEN IT COMES TO RACE.
THIS IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
RIDING ON AND IT'S A UNICYCLE
WITH A FLAT TIRE.
IF YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
BAD WHITES DO, WHAT ABOUT WHAT
GOOD POINTS DO ONE A WHITE
PERSON DO SOMETHING GREAT,
SHOULD YOU APPLAUD ME?
DOES ELON MUSK PRIVATIZING SPAC
TRAVEL AND BUILDING ELECTRIC
CARS ALLOW ME HAVING THE SAME
PIGMENT AS A MASS SHOOTER OR ME
AS A PARTY DANCING LIKE I'M IN
BODY CAST.
ISN'T THAT TRUE, WHITE SUPREMAC
THAT BY VIRTUE OF RACE I PLAYED
A ROLE IN INVENTING AIR TRAVEL.
I ACTUALLY DID MORE THAN ONCE I
COLLEGE I TOOK ASKED THAT I OFF
THE LIBRARY ROOF INTO TRASH.
BY THIS LOGIC, I OWN EVERYTHING
GOOD AND EVERYTHING BAD, WHICH
IS NOT NUTS.
BY SAYING THAT ALL WHITES ARE
COMPLICIT IN THE ECZEMA BAD MAN
HE'S A TRUE WHITE SUPREMACIST
AND IF WHITES PUT A MAN ON THE
MOON,  I GUESS THAT I MIGHT AS
WELL BE BUZZ ALDRIN.
AND YOU'RE WELCOME FOR THE TAG.
IDIOTIC.
IT IS IDIOTIC.
BUT LET'S PLAY THIS GAME PURGE
OF ALL THE JAPANESE SHARE A
GUILD FOR PEARL HARBOR AND SHOO
ALL JAPANESE BE CREDITED WITH
THE BEST TOILETS ON EARTH.
ADMITTED.
I'M PRETTY GOOD.
VERY CLEAN.
CHEVAL GERMANS ANSWER FOR THE
HOLOCAUST?
I SAY, YES, EXCEPT FOR HEIDI
CLUNE BUT THEY ALSO GAVE THE
PRETZELS.
SHOULD ALL BLACKS BE CREDITED
WITH INVENTING THE BEST MUSIC
EVER.
I BET YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THEY COME UP WITH POLKA MUSIC
BUT THEY'RE ALSO PARTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE BLACK-EYED
PEAS.
I KNOW.
YOU SEE HOW THIS LOGIC IS CNN I
THE WORST OF THE GROUP APPEARED
HOW WHAT THEY FEEL IF WE JUDGE
THEM BY JOY REED OR JEFFREY
TOOBIN.
ACTUALLY I DO.
ALL THE TIME.
I'M A HYPOCRITE.
IT'S A PART OF THEIR SINGLE
VARIABLE THINKING THEY HAVE NO
MENTAL DASHBOARD AS THEY FLY
THROUGH LIFE STORMS NO
PROBABILITY, EXPERIENCE.
THEY SEE LIFE THROUGH ONE FILTER
, RACE.
SO WHAT ABOUT ME.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED, I'
SURE IT APPEARED THE NEW
RESEARCH ON VIOLENT CRIME, SHOR
MEN WERE TWICE AS LIKELY TO BE
CONVICTED OF A CRIME AS THE
TALLEST.
NOW MAYBE THOSE GUYS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO TAKE A SWING AT DANNY
DEVITO THAN DEWAYNE JOHNSON.
BUT THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT THE
REAL VARIABLE PREDICTING VIOLEN
CRIME WAS IQ.
IT IS THE SHORT GUIDE TO BLAMES
I'M OFF THE HOOK FOR STEALING A
BIG WHEEL.
IT'S NOT JUST WITHIN SHORT
PEOPLE THAT DIFFERENCES LIKE IQ
OCCUR.
HAPPENS IN ALL GROUPS.
THIS FIGURE DIFFERENCES WITHIN
ONE GROUP THEN THERE ARE BETWEE
TWO GROUPS.
IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE AN EINSTEIN
AND A TOM ARNOLD.
IT'S WHY YOU HAVE THOMAS SOUL
AND JOY REED.
THEIR BIGGER DIFFERENCES WITHIN
RACE THEN BETWEEN RACES THAT IS
HUGE.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE ARE INDIVIDUALS.
WE ARE BRILLIANT, FUNNY, WEIRD,
HIGH IQ, BUT ENOUGH ABOUT ME.
WERE ALSO DEPRESSED AND CRAZY
INVULNERABLE AND DANGEROUS.
ENOUGH ABOUT KAT.
BUT IT IS NOT BETWEEN GROUPS.
IT'S AMONG PEOPLE, INDIVIDUALS
SO DO MY OWN EXPLANATION FOR
SHORT AND VIOLENT BECAUSE I'M
SHORT, NOPE JUST BECAUSE I DON'
TAKE CREDIT FOR ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT LITTLE PEOPLE DO.
BUT IF YOU FAVOR GROUP IDENTITY
OVER THE INDIVIDUAL, YOU WOULD,
BUT YOU DON'T BECAUSE WE SEE TH
PERSON COME ONLY IF THE LEFT OF
THE IMMEDIACY GROUPS PER THE
ONLY HERD MENTALITY AT OUR HEAD
IS WALKING AWAY FROM THEM AND
THE ONLY PLACE LEFT US WANT THE
PATIENT IS IN MATH CLASS.
LOOK AT KAT AND TYRUS AND ME,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO GAI
FROM THE SHOW IS THAT WE ARE
DIFFERENT PERSONS.
I DON'T SEE KAT AS A WHITE CHICK
.
TYRUS IS A WHITE MALE.
YOU DOESN'T SEEM HE IS AT ALL
DEPENDING HOW CLOSE OR FAR I AM
TO HIM.
NOR DO I SEE THEM AS A GIANT WH
CAN FLICK ME INTO SPACE WITH HI
PINKY.
I SEE HE'S THE SMARTEST GUY I'V
EVER MET PICK I JUST HOPE THAT
COULD LOWEST WATCHING.
I TOLD HIM THE SAME THING IN TH
STEAM ROOM.
NIC AND I SEEK IS THE FUNNIEST
CREATURE ON EARTH THAT SHE'S NO
EVEN TRYING TO BE FUNNY OR SHE
IS JUST BEING KAT.
SO IN SHORT, WHITE SUPREMACY
IDENTITY POLITICS, AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING RIGHT NOW ON THE SHOW
IS WE EMBRACE THE PERSON, NOT
THE PIGMENT, SO SCREECH YOUR
IDENTITY BECAUSE IT'S AN EVIL
THAT HELPS NO RACE PICKETS JUST
ABOUT POWER AS EVIL ALWAYS IS.
WILL COME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
FORMER SPORTS CASTER, MICHELLE
GOETSCH.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE TRIED TO
CANCEL HIM, YOU WOULD THINK HIS
NAME WAS CNN PLUS.
DAVE RUBIN.
GIVE HER LIBERTY OR GIVE HER
ANYTHING BUT A SHOT OF TEQUILA
PER FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT
TIMPF.
AND POPEYE WANTS TO KNOW WHAT H
EATS.
DEBBIE DEBBIE E WORLD TELEVISIO
CHAMPION TYRUS.
SO, TYRUS, SHORT PEOPLE AREN'T
MORE LIKELY TWO VIOLENT CRIME,
GOING AGAINST YOUR THEORIES.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY SAID THEY
WERE.
IT WAS JUST THE SMART ONES DON'
GET CAUGHT.
YOU LEAD YOUR LEAGUE OF MARY
TITLE MEN AND THEN YOU HAVE THI
CODE OF SHORT VALOR OR YOU WON'
TELL ON EACH OTHER.
WELL PLAYED, PENGUIN.
YOU KNOW, GREAT MONOLOGUE
PHENOMENAL MONOLOGUE.
[APPLAUSE]
AS SOMEONE WHO GREW UP WITH
SOMETHING BAD HAPPEN ON THE NEW
COME ACROSS MY FINGERS LIKE
PLEASE DON'T BE A BROTHER
BECAUSE WE ALL GET BLAMED FOR IT
.
NOW WHEN WE GET TO THIS POINT O
EQUALITY, NOT ME BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO BE GROUPED
, BUT WHEN SOMEONE GETS
TO GO ON TV AND THEIR PLIGHT IS
TO GROUP OF WHITE PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND SAY THEY ARE ALL
BAD, YOU ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN
EARL ON THE PORCH.
IT IS THE SAME THING PICKETS
JUST BECAUSE WHEN THEY SAY IT,
THEY ARE SAYING IT FROM A PLACE
OF SUPPOSED WISDOM AND THEY ARE
NOT.
THEY'RE JUST RUNNING THE RACE
GAME JUST BECAUSE IT'S COMING
FROM A PERSON OF COLOR AND
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO PASS BECAUS
THEY HAVE CONVINCED WHITE
AMERICANS TO BE AFRAID TO SAY
THAT IS WRONG.
YOU SO HAPPEN TO BE BLACK BUT
THAT IS OKAY.
AMERICANS --
WHITE AMERICA HAS TO STAND UP
FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY DON'T OWN PLANTATIONS.
THEY'VE GOT TO PAY BILLS.
WE ALL HAD THE SAME ISSUES IN
THE SAME HURDLES.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
COLOR OF LIFE NOR WOULD LIVE.
THEY'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE THAT
IS THE EASIEST WAY TO GET
ATTENTION.
THERE WAS A LOT OF MURDERS AND
THEY ONLY FOCUS ON ONE, WHY,
BECAUSE PEOPLE TUNE IN.
THAT IS THE TRAGEDY OF APPEARED.
>> TO BE TOTALLY CLEAR, JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL
KNOW THAT NO ONE IN THIS
BUILDING HAS A ROOM IN THEIR
BASEMENT.
EXPECTS NO, NO.
I CAN'T STRESS THAT ENOUGH
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO PRIVATE
LOCKER ROOM RIGHT NEXT TO THE
MAILROOM.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M THINKING.
I'M SORRY.
>> YOU WERE DOING SO WELL I WAS
ALMOST A SERIOUS PERSON.
YOU ARE OUR FIRST SHOW.
I DOUBTED YOU WHAT DID YOU SAY
ON THE FIRST SHOW QUICK.
>> BEFORE I TELL YOU, ON THE
OPTIONS THAT I SAY SOMETHING
OFFENSIVE HERE DURING THE
PROGRAM, DOING THE HO AS A BLACK
, IDENTIFYING AS TODAY, BUT
ON THE FIRST SHOW, THE FIRST
"GUTFELD" SHOW I WAS SITTING IN
THIS CHAIR AND I SAID YOU WOULD
BE THE NUMBER ONE KING AND
LATE-NIGHT WITHIN ONE YEAR.
I SAID, NO, IT'S NOT POSSIBLE
PROVIDE DOUBTED YOU.
AND I DOUBTED YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE SHORT.
I AM GLAD WE CAN STACK UP
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
EXPECTS I WILL BE PROBABLY THE
SHORT ONE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF YOU HAVE A
OPINION.
I AM WITH CHILD, PLEASE.
I'M TOLD YOU CAN GET AN ABORTIO
IF IT'S NECESSARY PERSPEX BEARD
DOING THAT STORY TOMORROW.
WE USED TO BE ALL ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS.
NOW IT'S ALL ABOUT GROUPS.
EXPECTS THE BEST EXAMPLE THAT
YOU SHOW WAS THOMAS SOUL.
IT DOES NOT MATTER PAID SKIN
COLOR DOES NOT MATTER APPEARED
PROBABLY THE MOST GENIUS THAT
WE'VE EVER HAD IN HISTORY AND
SHE IS AN IDIOT WHO WORKS AT A
MENTAL INSTITUTION.
AND THOSE PEOPLE, THEIR SKIN
COLOR HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THOSE FACTS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THEM, THAT IS THE BEAUTY OF WHA
TYRUS WAS SAYING PICK UP YOU
LOOK AT THEM AND GOT THAT IT IS
A BLACK MAN HE MUST THINK THIS
WAY OR THINK THAT'S ABOUT
ECONOMICS AND SHE HAS A BLACK
WOMAN SHE MUST THINK THAT'S.
LOOK IN THE MIRROR BECAUSE YOU
ARE THE RACES.
>> I LOOK AT THIS AND I THINK
ABOUT MYSELF IN THE EARLY 2000s
OF BEING ACCUSED OF
OBAMA POLL BFP AT THIS IS A NEW
VERSION PAID SOMETIMES I THINK
MIGHT'VE BEEN GUILTY LIKE
BECAUSE OF 9-11, I WAS LIKE, I
WAS LOOKING EVERYWHERE SO IF I
HAVE TO ACCUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE
DOING THAT, FLICK MYSELF AND SE
BUT IT'S KIND OF THE SAME THING
IN A WAY.
>> YOU'RE STARTING WITH WITH TH
MAN IN THE MIRROR.
SO THEY DO BASED ON GENDER AS
WELL.
REMEMBER WHEN WE HELP THE WAR O
WOMEN A WHILE BACK, HILLARY
CLINTON TELLING US ALL THAT
WOMEN WERE OPPRESSED AND THE WA
ON WOMEN.
EUROPE WAS WORKING AS A WOMAN I
SPORTS, ONE OF THE VERY FEW AND
I WAS LIKE WHERE IS THAT I DON'
SEE IT.
I JUST THINK THAT PEOPLE FORGET
THAT WE ARE INDIVIDUALS.
AND IF YOU SAY THAT SOMEONE IS
NOT AN INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR ONL
PART OF A GROUP, IT IS BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE ANOTHER ARGUMENT.
YOU DON'T GIVE THAT PERSON
AGENCY OVER THEIR OWN LIFE.
YOU ARE SAYING IT IS TOO BAD
THAT YOU ARE A WHITE HISPANIC
WOMAN.
YOU WILL NEVER BE A SPORTSCASTE
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T.
>> THEY SAID THAT TO ME.
>> DID THEY QUICK.
>> OF WHAT UPHELD --
>> Greg: WHICH IS WHY I
TRANSITIONED FROM A SHORT MAN O
GERMAN AND JEWISH --
>> CAN I JUST MENTION --
>> LEGENDARY SPORTSCASTER, TELL
THE TRUTH.
I SHALL MENTION MICHAEL JACKSON.
ONLY IN ONE OF THE COUNTRY COUL
YOUNG BLACK MEN GO UP TO BE AN
OLD WHITE WOMAN.
ALL RIGHT, KAT, YOU ARE IN A
GROUP OF ONE, SO TO SPEAK.
HOW DO YOU GET PEOPLE TO BREAK
OUT OF THIS IDEA OF THIS
GROUPTHINK APPEARED.
>> THE FIRST VERSION OF YOUR
MODEL LOT THAT I READ, YOU --
TODAY I DECIDED TO TRAIN --
YOU DECIDED TO CHANGE PERSON
INTO CREATURE APPEARS.
>> I DIDN'T NOTICE THAT.
>> WELCOME IT IS MORE ACCURATE.
I THINK THAT IT'S NOT GOOD TO
VIEW EVERYTHING THROUGH A
PREDETERMINED LENS, NO MATTER
WHAT THAT LENS IS THESE PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY DO IT WITH GRACE.
IF YOU ALREADY KNOW IT BEFORE
YOU'D LOOK AT SOMETHING, YOU'RE
NOT THINKING AT ALL.
YOU CAN'T THINK CRITICALLY AND
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO BE A GOOD
THING PIXEL I THINK THAT LOOKIN
AT THE SITUATION INDIVIDUALLY
AND AS PEOPLE INDIVIDUALLY AS
THE ONLY WAY THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE PROCESSING
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
>> GOOD POINT.
>> THANKS.
BEFORE WE GO COME A QUICK
REMINDER I WILL BE IN SALT LAKE
CITY, WHICH IS IN UTAH THIS
SATURDAY FOR MY BOOK TOUR AND
TYRUS WILL BE THERE.
WE'VE GOT SOME NEW --
GO TO G GOT FELL.com.